[Music]
I'm so excited we're finally going to
Puerto Rico and bringing your donations
over we got aquatab water filters
generators doctors and we're flying in
all over right now we had friends donate
their planes to help bring the aid down
to the island along with 12 physicians
who all volunteered their time to stay
behind on the island and help the people
in need I wanted to be able to help on a
larger scale because I have such a large
audience and it's my responsibility to
help create awareness this is a
humanitarian crisis and it doesn't
matter what your gender is what your
culture is where you're from we're all
human and we need to work together to
make this world a better place
[Music]
Porto Rico has faced a devastating
hurricane that has left the island
without water and without power
[Music]
it feels amazing to know that I can
influence others and be good
[Music]
don't eating any amount helps and even
just sharing this video if you can't
donate helps create awareness you know
if I can inspire you guys imagine who
you can inspire